what's a fool podcast
what's a fool podcast welcome to the
podcast
we got rid of our okay we're gonna start
off bro an April Fool's where you guys
are not here no more and it only meet my
young male
I'm the new guest oh yeah show up
otherwise minded stupid I saw the lobby
too real time right there hello brother
like that we're on now yeah what's up
fool podcast we got our three were
Tori's we got Johnny Ruffy over here man
stay for function in the work the more
The Wanderers and Lisa right here man
winter suit Mike your works ma de troyes
finest not only Lee Troy finding but
he's also Windsor Canada finest I mean
I've been over there many many times
nineteen-year-old drinking well I saw
this for one time and when I opened up
for um Russell Peters when I was in
Windsor yeah Ceaser's he showed up
showed up Russell gave me that tight
tight tent
yeah keep it tight his brother sent me
home with half my money we had a good
time hey brick we've known each other a
long time long time Philippe one of the
good ones
what's up fool the good ones we used to
sit outside bro when it was no comedy
well outside was dead would you listen
to old joe rogan story without well he
wasn't there anymore
yeah with me Mike young and I met I'm an
inbred Earth old-school problem and they
were into political argument blog was
our Brenner so tight and I'd be like
okay nobody will talk about something
that was like who's going up tomorrow
who's gonna [ __ ] try to go up at um
that [ __ ] Club that
don't leave early to host Dublin's
Dublin's bro
classic bro did you party like those
guys will you never party now I'm not a
party but I was never like a big partier
no I was about but huh yeah just hit
hard like my Jack and cokes sip my
tequila I'll never sign as a drinker no
well I just like I'm a slow sipper I'm a
slow simple board I guess that's idler
bro you know rather than my young he's
doing here yeah you know what I mean I
just take it slow Phillippi I don't I
don't get out of hand I don't black out
I don't go crazy I gotta keep my wits
about me no common story first aid when
was the first thing we went there wow
man I mean he was like 19 95 or 96 they
were those are an audition for comedy
compadres you know that show that column
is here with hosting for Jim about date
on channel 5 it's where they showcase
yeah I heard a body but I didn't know
where the comedy store was at the time
oh yeah I was doing of the natural pudge
getting bumped by a [ __ ] al Berman and
Jamie Kennedy in Synthia Varela being
damn Byron Keith Andrew big antenna or
in the morning twinkle bump everybody I
don't see I came into the comedy store
that was the first place I ever
performed so it was like 96 I was
waiting in line on Sundays
I was in the Sunday you know waiting
virtually yeah
Chewie was talking slangin dope out the
back that nobody knew about for 10 years
you know I mean he was running he was
running the show and and I was open
doing the open mic three minutes shift
there for a while
and then boom I got lucky I got I got
pat you know Sebastian Brett you Joey
Diaz like that was kind of like the crew
that I came at Bobby Lee that's like the
crew that I can Martinez yeah yeah yeah
rest rest
RIPD was sweet but uh yeah but we were
there when it was kind of empty yeah my
[ __ ] was going down room to room brought
back there brought people that give a
[ __ ] but the committee would just bring
their dog on stage it was this kind of
stunt Todd I saw him with tiny brother
daughter stays didn't want to get off
yeah we did more [ __ ] in that building
that I ever did Brooke for a wild man
that was like when to enjoy
before joe rogan had the Joe Rogan
experience he had Joe Rome the dotnet
yeah and he was doing that show full-fat
house if you're a factor in factor you
know I was opening for him he asked me
on the road what was that like back then
with a patch shows right pack shows when
he was doing Fear Factor going on the
road this is Rogan pre we'd see smoke
weed then he just grappled you know he
knew he was gonna get into the UFC like
we'd go to those gyms but it was pre UFC
but they were still talking to him about
potentially doing that but it was like
my first experience of being a playing
in front of packed houses and like the
girls on the road and like real it was
real road [ __ ] with Joe Rogan yeah I
mean I looked I was like cuz I'm single
back then he was single I was single I
was like yo bro I'm from Detroit I never
seen a [ __ ] like this I just want to say
thank you
I don't know how Hollywood works I don't
know if I owe you a [ __ ] I don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on but I feel
lucky to be here
so I throw to the first time somebody
gave me like a lot of money I like what
I got we're gonna kill ya mycology cos
man like he gave me more money than I
ever made in like five months for three
days yeah like whoa okay yeah police is
gonna be now every time we showed up to
the Laugh Factory
I didn't drink I knew his favorite drink
it was on something really really [ __ ]
up him strong it was scotch and coffee
he thought it was strong brother real
strong and he'll show up it was a pause
and I'll give it to him like [ __ ]
Henry Hill passing every last possible
hell yeah you gotta yo it's the politics
of Facebook well everybody's complaining
I'm over there talking naming it Network
you were the only wedding important here
yeah complaining I started grappling I
don't grapple oh yeah I was like yo Joe
whatever you need bro I'll be in the gym
put me in a chokehold that like blow
people think that you go open for
somebody to be in your own hotel room
now but you gotta kick a dog yeah you
got a kick of Hillary I'm gonna call you
back no I was with him for a year gonna
radio I started not kicking it that's
when I got thrown off the table I'm
gonna kick your tough sleepy
at some point I'm like you're all right
kid I got a nice [ __ ] cold room no
more I'm making it in the cold plunge
I'm not making it to [ __ ] challenge
to lunch and I'm not ground not
wrestling
I don't wrestle I'll hit them I'll hit
the heavy bag I live very light weights
I know man like when you hang all the
community that brings money you're like
what the [ __ ]
you know Willie Barcena and that food
making it get bad chicks bro life of
doing college is like and he ever gonna
stack blood uncashed that's a thing you
doing a really young comic over you
leave three checks are not cached from
people like he has all these uncashed
checks liner yeah checks that luke tori
is actually not him Luke Torres had
these I don't know we was going through
you live in his car we had like three
checks and I gave them to him and he was
a you gonna catch these and I didn't
know back then why didn't want to catch
a bear with child support but well you
wanna catch up a liquor store bro to a
bank
yeah man saw I didn't realize that
that's like a real thing because Brian
kept bragging about the check CD in cash
well I cashed the check and I get the
cash I keep the cash I don't there's no
uncashed checks around it's just gonna
go bad again
there's no uncashed checks Lisa I asked
my wife mm now it was 2008 2009 we were
was at I was like doing every [ __ ]
show at the Laugh Factory right how the
sounds all right I was doing every
shorts at Laugh Factory you and I went
over to get my check and I and then I
saw like okay I had like three checks I
did every freaking show up like for one
month bro and it was a good check but
then I looked at the [ __ ] out the
[ __ ] list Bob Saget but the
Chancellor he claimed when I saw Harland
Williams mmm me a pile of bear waiting
for 25 bucks bro Shaggy's got $19,000
with it
yes $35 he's hired
oh so hanging over Willie right and
therefore was doing colleges he's doing
clubs
he got development deals bro I'm new I
got bad teeth you know I'm living up my
dad's money they I'm holding for him you
know I'm taking it
ha ha as far as a family nobody knows
about the turn and regret it now and oh
and then like I'm thinking thankfully
three times a day bro can't even treat
him well I think here about treating but
but like my family to each other day bro
ie one time that's it I could I gotta go
to the movies again but I backed it with
a comedian by working on my knee bro it
was a lot of my money
it's a scrappy game and you got to play
that like you said that that politics
like I was on the road for a year with
Rogan you know but then I really wasn't
hanging out like that like I'm just I
can only hang out so much I'm getting
the 12 o'clock lunch call but whenever
you got to be at lunch at 12:00
he's got Brian who's red band is his
assistant at the time
he's got the you know he's like the
computer wizard kid that's like
heartbroken over his girl and I were
just you know Duncan Trussell zhan the
road and it's like Joe was just like yo
be at lunch at 12:00 and I did that for
like a year but then then yeah I started
not hanging as much and next thing you
know BAM that call doesn't come you know
but you gotta be you gotta man up and be
your own yeah I started doing like I got
a blow and getting [ __ ] up when I was
opening up for it fluffy get really less
yes yeah and um I was just getting tired
man like like tired of waiting to eat
when they wanted to eat yeah they were
good they were go to sleep before 5:00
in the morning playing Madden smoking
weed and then oh they'll really will get
up and run eat a - yeah like a full
[ __ ] meal right - a PM Fumio like
breakfast we're talking lunch breakfast
right eggs pancakes Cracker Barrel style
man and then we get to the show we [ __ ]
up the show food but then this foreigner
go [ __ ] out dinner dies and drives at
20 morning go bro we're not that size
and then you go I'm not that size
in there and they're like we're over
there bro they got like but this they
got like calm we ate at 200 more one
midnight but it was good food man but it
was a lot bro you were eight and up top
of the gorge or stop for the G Joe Topo
Gigio ready to zany's no Chicago is an
Italian restaurant I thought we were
just gonna order food now bro yeah they
kept bringing food yes then they brought
our there but first they had like a
regular meal it was like bread and
butter and [ __ ] olive oil right it's
got courses yeah courses right and then
it would like like a little bit of
cheese on it not a lot then they brought
up they brought up [ __ ] those little
tiny ribs background yeah short rib
short ribs yeah they were all spiced or
was they were delicious yeah it was they
were good after that after after there
was a lot of like a lot of like juice
for nothing that guy the guy the manager
who do you guys doing it was oh so many
good grab that brittle dippers was
everywhere oh my god I was tasting it
buddy everyone's fingers yeah but that
then they brought pizza like real thin
[ __ ] pizza yeah then our [ __ ] then
they brought our concept then they
brought our meals which were huge meals
after our meals they brought up a big
layer of a bunch of spumoni nowhere that
[ __ ] phony and there was like a bunch
of little cakes all over the [ __ ]
table fruit no I don't do I don't do we
ate okay we ate all that right they got
in the way home there was like a pizza
like a like a cheesesteak badger
he turned a running on who on the
Cheesecake Factory and I said [ __ ] that
[ __ ] and everybody laughed you know on
you don't know it done yeah bro but
you're gonna you're gonna be a healthier
person for getting off that [ __ ] tour
you know I mean he was trying to get you
to be his size you think that you don't
have it like that I don't got time for
no knee surgery bro no no bro you're
fully on the road right now I got its
protein only right now I think that he
had a personal trainer at one time and
that fool could have had he quit is it
Mac come again about to begin with you
guys yeah we're going backwards the
trainer was getting out of shape he were
smoking room yeah
I know I know but that is interesting
cuz you gotta as you when you're coming
up and you're opening for somebody you
got a deal with that [ __ ] politics or
how do you handle I mean yo I'm jr. from
now Johnny let me say man I like to
learn he was by himself up on the
building I'm like Rob enough we should
let this duty seems maybe like something
was up cuz his jacket was nice I was
like I'm like I'm like his [ __ ] looks
tired but he's got a nice jacket shiny
yeah I know what that is though bro you
gotta you gotta play that personality
game you know but like you know you're
not like that you're not dragging
everybody you're doing writing you got
your boys with you you're not gonna make
them do this eat this had some BBQ bro
grape oh yeah I think I think they had
they had he made them once and they with
the whole he got the whole crew and they
had a hamburger eating contest yeah well
everybody apologies I walked away the
winner gets to all so merged see that's
just some [ __ ] that's torture that's
an ego torture [ __ ]
like I like people I like headliners
that just don't even call you like I was
Sebastian I did like nine shows them
recently you know I didn't even see him
we were on the same [ __ ] bus I didn't
see him he stayed in his back of his bus
he'd left me alone I left him alone he
wasn't asking for lunch
just stay there mean it's we're both men
[ __ ] live your life bro you don't
know I hate you so you know I'm not
making you my [ __ ] slave you ain't my
[ __ ] sidekick yeah man you know what
I mean
but that being said I give love to Joe
Rogan for bringing me out there show me
what it was to play in front of a
big-ass audience and [ __ ] orgy right
orgies and I don't want to disrespect
you know we could he's a woman in the
high your wife is yeah I could say some
things have happened on the road I've
seen it bro
I see I'm Joe
in it that [ __ ] that was not
cool a company I know but you had a
girlfriend the time yeah I didn't know
you had a girlfriend I knew I yeah
everyone knew you didn't know what's
appear that she's like five times bro
was it but you say okay I say my
Virginie so Joe Rogan man Joe Rogan died
man back in the day they got to remember
it was one damn he would have Joe Diaz
doing crazy [ __ ] man like busting out of
posters naked with his boots on and
chaos and keep her mind back then there
was no one at the cop nobody hold mine
in the Comedy Store
FTF tonight story if no one is mine in
the store like back then if you got you
probably got bullied because nobody's
watching [ __ ] man yeah I've thrown
chairs across the room back in the day
in the original room back day long Barry
was a man with it was the only one I had
a real job told he was the [ __ ] warm
up for our Kimmel the man show oh yeah
for the man show and he was working for
everybody I was just raping scraping by
it's creepy but I know Felipe he's
leading on to is this Sunday in late
Sunday night this crazy ass chick shows
up I'll never forget her bro she look
like [ __ ] that chick from Lost Boys I
don't know her name keeper Jamie Jamie
curse
yeah a chance glasses and then she's
good she's on his science trip because I
really I really thought about her that
he just wanted to be a freak she was
also a teacher to the teacher and she
just want to experience a whole
Hollywood nightlife she made I was a
bunch of dudes bro before the think they
I read everything and then she's giving
him a bj on stage but you don't see
nothing but the back of her head
yeah I got a I got a I got a I got a BJ
I got a [ __ ] on stage her Tommy store
one o'clock in the world nuts to another
Canadians car too though another
comedian nameless he goes up on stage
later on and makes out with her yeah and
then they put a little arrow they put a
little arrow on his mouth and hey look
at my jig no it didn't go that far but
the episode ended up on Joe Rogan
and Joe was up there taking there was
pictures [ __ ] was going down don't know
I had a girl I had a girl at the time
and so I couldn't I had to call Joe the
next angle bro please because you've
named my name bro please take you know
and I was living I'm like because part
of the dream is to do all that kind of
[ __ ] the dream of being a comedian is
being a comedian but it comes with like
sub dreams that was a submarine that was
a sub dream and I was living so did it
because of the sub dream yeah I was like
forced into it no no I was she was day I
had her dancing on stage first that she
took the giant coat off then she got on
her knees and I was like I came on I
[ __ ] turned around there was probably
five six people in the audience that yes
eight we were all crying come back there
you got me but he was said back then I
think the time he will come on and look
at the audience
1 2 3 4 11 we did a show totally because
there was no six no show 8 to 11 years
yeah it went down I had a girl at the
time next day my ship pops up on Joe
Rogan dotnet I had to call John go do
please you have to take this down my
girls like a Fanny or she could
potentially look at this so of course he
like blurs my face out yeah changes my
name but then writes like soo [ __ ] the
next sentence down like Mike Young was a
real [ __ ] last night like so gonna be
like it was like something funny but
like he had a gear to give me a little
jab just because I had made him take it
down yeah anyway that chick ain't no
hanging out for three more days bro
chill Wednesday and Joe Diaz calls me up
into a bro look at this chicken over
here she hung out for three days then by
the way it all before Rogan got married
it was game on bro
because I remember another girl at the
Comedy Store came beautiful and we walk
in the back and Rogen's like young take
her on a tour that was the tour was the
move so we could yo hallway move yo it
was a one hallway make a left go to it
there's seven empty bathrooms back then
like the place was deserted man there
was rooms everywhere bro
Yahoo's everywhere and it went down and
I did what I did with this girl and it's
in an empty [ __ ] room
and we walked back I thought she was by
herself or with her friends we walk out
me and Rogan are looking in there she's
on a date and she went from me and to
sit next to her date and I was like I
think it's I got to get out of here I
mean that's how you get killed that's
the Hollywood Life bro I thought I'd do
it out yeah bro it's all part of the
dream stealing car radios at night and
Bob dombarris showed up with those two
girls that do the jumping on the
trampoline but yeah [ __ ] load it bro
yeah they were [ __ ] loaded bro and I
was on stage and I said dumb bear you
know dumb baby I'm not crying anybody
here always tonight
any wish I'm a granted so what up the
man that we're going to be on stay with
two chicks a to take you up on stage bro
awesome and then [ __ ] on the Diceman
aback clapping that yeah jeez I approve
yeah those were the days of the comedy
you know many people were there bro
seven yeah I'm on the co-ceo Gabriel
glanced at Tony Sanchez Ivan Cuellar and
a bunch of comedians in the back yeah we
used to have a girl in there
you do remember when you would do a joke
you had the best [ __ ] line when a
child didn't go so well
did I or whether my Creek I don't know
who it was
it was look back in her days yeah I was
waiting know the beginning days but on
people saying you know they do a movie
but the comedy story were no happening
now the real movie was when it wasn't
happening 100% 100% not the excitement
when you had that shake it was really
going down when it was empty I would you
have the Freddy Novak's you know going
up people late at night either run or
that one guy in the Guitar Rig real bad
right right here's the closing I was
there with a Gilligan's Island
you know the Charles Fleischer doing
cartoon voices and what they're doing
that black voice for the big laugh yeah
yeah your nose carpentry yeah like some
[ __ ] on the mic to like the road
ya know those were the days oh who the
damn dude where Eddie Griffin walk in
and you're bumping for four hours
yo bro do you remember do you remember
the number the night I got beat up oh do
you member that night you got beat up by
who remember I got like a little bit of
trouble with like some organized crime
situation do you member that hole do you
remember that at all so I got it's a bad
story I'm not gonna tell the whole story
but I got in trouble with the wrong
people I didn't know what happened and
long story no pressure at the car at the
laughs fact it wasn't perfect but it was
like some people like Pesci's world and
I had out I was working no wasn't
gambling I was doing a [ __ ] I was I
was hosting a comedy night a fight broke
out dr. Guido night it was a bassist and
Guido [ __ ] [ __ ] being Joey yo I got in a
fight I beat up a dude he was a
connected guy I got in bad trouble long
story short I went to hide at the Comedy
Store after I beat him up cuz I heard
who he was and he was looking for me and
I go up there and it's like artful you
know and it's the one night that Eddie
Griffin decides not to do an hour so I'm
hiding out all messed up Sam Tripoli
sees music hey what's wrong I'm like the
[ __ ] mobs after me and I got blood on
my neck I'm a mess from the whole thing
and Eddie Griffin gets off after 10
minutes and they're like yo Mike you're
up next I'm like I can't go on tonight
like that I can't go on tonight like
they're looking for me in the streets
but I ended up going on and I was so
scared I didn't tell a single joke no
joke I didn't tell a joke I stayed on
just like mumbling for like out of fear
for like 10 15 minutes but Eddie Griffin
usually went on for an hour and a half
no one said anything this night he
decides to get off ten minutes they're
like Mike you're up Dan I'm like yo
organized crimes looking for me I got to
get off stage I start the fight started
bro while I'm on the microphone doing
something I'm on the mic and a dude gets
head-butted right in front of me oh do
get head-butted
yo and I jumped down like a stupid ass
and I'm like yo bro calm down and he's
in a suit and he's like yo bro you know
who I am you know you know You Know Who
I am
and I'm thinking to myself this dude
seems like a pit bull like he's got that
type of [ __ ] like the veins are popping
and he just had bunted no one's head
butted in 50 years that movie except for
Willie Barcena no one had bucks
I tried to calm it down he told me he's
gonna kill me he starts waving his hand
like this over my head and out of
instinct and stupidity boom I swung on
cannoli I swung on him and the [ __ ] went
down and I don't want to tell the whole
story just because it's crazy but let's
just say organized crime division police
were coming to see me it became a whole
serious real thing Wow a very real thing
funny you say that because there was a
one night that I'm fluffy and I were
somebody called it and told her that
they were gonna put our names on the
comedy store wall yeah so they put our
names up right yeah so I'm standing
right outside going okay so right across
the street whatever that hotel though
what he called Roger yeah yeah some
[ __ ] Guido guy is standing right
there he just standing there but he just
standing there bro 10 [ __ ]
continental truck those [ __ ] Chrysler
trucks show up our tow truck shows up
they [ __ ] handcuffed him they took
off his shoes they put him inside a
truck and they [ __ ] tow his car no
question is that like the [ __ ]
swooped yeah maybe with the protection
program maybe you [ __ ] you you're
gone [ __ ] he's a fugitive from
the law
but dude no ray there was no LAPD there
was nobody there bro our last marshals
yeah yeah when they got when they found
out when my thing was going on I was
getting visited by LAPD and highway
manager every week they were coming at
me because they wanted me to try to
press charges against the dude and I
just never talked so they kept coming to
me coming to me and I just stay silent
can't get affirmed murderers they want
to get it from assault but it became a
whole other thing dude I beat up the
wrong dude for real
I heard him one punch I threw in ten
years I hadn't been watching 89 you know
it was a Tommy Hearns
heavy hand long marinos you get though
the bet yeah but you know Moreno I need
your merch for sure he might not even be
Italian I live
Capone's kids and they had one there one
brother they were all dark dark hair
dark eyes dark skin
he was blonde blue eyes whose name is
Aurora Colorado but they moved from
Brooklyn yeah if your family lit up and
they came to Colorado
yeah yeah you'll find people that's a
beautiful thing though about stand-up
comedy you meet all kinds of characters
yeah man so when the [ __ ] was kind of
going down with me
there were people listen I always say
like when you make people laugh and I
know you've got you've already got this
like there's bad people who love you
yeah like Felipe head god forbid some
problems I guarantee there's numbers he
could call and they'd be like yo bro we
[ __ ] love you bro what are you two
two thousand dollars we'll take care of
everything I think you got free tickets
to the next show hang on the greenroom
but that's like the beauty of stand-up
is that like you make friends with bed
like from even Saget the nicest person
in the world who plays like now you know
the TV's favorite father has a leg
breaker we were young now he doesn't
have a butt like we were doing a show
somewhere seven bikers from like a biker
gang showed up they're like Bob like cuz
Bob did like a reality show well yeah so
they loved him fresh off the bikes
vasin you know me motor surveys love sag
you when I was well open up for Russell
Peters in kelowna
in the Canada like Russell family with
Austrian over there Russell was gambling
but I was with on the Russell's table
but other than the last part of the
table there other projects the one ain't
gonna get no meat no bread so but I was
sitting with these white dudes and we
were just telling jokes forever it turns
out they were just old Hells Angels yep
I had the other bounce there HEA they
had 80 ones but there was a local who
tell you something there were like Bloor
telling jokes bro like I had one blue
teller job these other girls on the job
manager Barney and [ __ ] joke baby
were laughing yeah but firstly anytime
you want to come down and buy the to
show that's uh if ever there was a
problem Russell's somebody I would call
because Russell is connecting you know
everyone got the ring bro like like he
hosted like angels like one of their
weddings Kelowna in love him they love
him you know after one of the shows that
the factory Russell's
okay dinner with us Daniel was there a
raid on one other chapters and his name
came up - I don't know I didn't see that
sounds good great by financing his own
chapter he well Russell can't ride a
motorcycle
yeah no no I know paper yeah we went to
uh yeah we after the show with the fact
that me Russell and Chuck Zito was the
original member dudes went to eat at the
Rainbow Room
you know tuxedos you know he's priced 60
years old but he'll still rip a phone
book in half there's pictures of them
all over the Rainbow Room - you know
it's one of the cool things about comedy
you meet a lot of characters what's up
fool it's time for the Joey cocoa minute
bro brought wrote down his words bro you
gotta make it right now
joyeux Cody about this 1978 Queen's
partner cause diamonds mucho cierra bro
this guy used to make bombs [ __ ] Isis
before I was [ __ ] Isis with one
[ __ ] I was like Robocop boom start
out with the story bro 1978 thought
that's what you would do Joey Diaz did
time he did he was he was locked up for
nine months right told me it's always
the perfect amount of time for pregnancy
[Laughter]
so I count those [ __ ] boughs are over
here bro
yo Felipe what's going on here is the
tour yeah one leaks to the manager yeah
no I know that she's running the show
you open yeah yeah yeah middle yeah okay
like a guest but and then most the time
we'll pull in a local feature in there
yeah yeah yeah no I'd love to see you I
love it man I mean I've known Felipe
forever bro we were you know I mean just
two dudes lingering from different
cultures
I mean YouTube yo DS you know me a Jew
from Detroit and I don't even know where
you're from but I used to be a joy
neighborhood there you go
you grew up out here yeah I know that I
think I might have known that I departed
the Seattle with palled knuckle yo by
the way you just Rabbani be like but
when the store was empty it's cuz I got
Bobby Lee's picture right in front of me
yeah you know I literally almost ruined
Bobby Lee's career when he first when he
got mad TV or in the middle of MADtv
Bobby leaves you know like back in the
day he wasn't sober he was a disaster if
you saw you saw probably walking in with
overalls but he was Chucky bro
yeah he was [ __ ] rolling up the
Elmer's glue in his fingers you know I
mean he was just a mess but he was like
Mike Young I'm making money I'm killing
it let's get it let's get some hookers
I'm like alright maybe we do I'm not
afraid
Bobby Lee goes to the back of the LA
Weekly review and they went was I Bobby
Lee's like finds a number in the back of
LA Weekly calls their paper yeah he's
like you're driving down to the motel
down the street right we go down
something like you know a [ __ ] again
sub sub dream part of the dream live the
dream my boys on MADtv he wants to get
hookers let's go we're doing it all see
what happens
Bobby Lee we go down there and we pull
into the motel we go up the stairs to
the room that were supposed to go to I
look to the left
I got the street sense I know what's
going on I saw like a guy and a girl
just lingering so how does it look right
I'm gonna hook ur
yep I hate hey wouldn't one of you [ __ ]
when you cooking column and I say no
driver and a driver shows up yeah this
was this wasn't a driver though I could
tell these were two cops waiting for a
sting operation
so I said Bobby this isn't good bro
there's a sting operation about we're
not going in
he said no [ __ ] I'm going in I'm like
I'll be in the car
like you do what you got to do but when
you go and make sure you ask her if
she's a cop Bobby Lee doesn't care he
goes in and I'm sitting in the car at 40
seconds later he comes out running down
the stairs because she wouldn't answer
him next day next night on the news
major prostitution ring busted at that
motel
st. Motel shut it down I said I saved
Bobby and almost ruined him in one night
good-sized story ah I don't like talking
about that [ __ ] in front of your wife
bro yeah no no we but but back in the
day you're right the show should be done
about the empty the end okay because you
know yeah Brian Holtzman there he was a
Manimal Johnny Sanchez he ain't no angel
Freddy solo rest their peace don't
forget about another successful comedian
at the time who Freddie Freddie
god I love Freddie man the best that I
think I ever had was before Freddie came
on I had just the perfect amount of weed
and tequila and I don't know what kind
of zone I was in but I was on autopilot
I remember Freddie came up and he's like
how do you follow that but he followed
it and you know it was crazy [ __ ]
Freddie man he was such a good dude I
went where did he pass away in Phoenix
no other early Hollywood it was right
after he did Tempe though like he had
just just got back right so I did Tempe
the week after him and and at the time
Dan Murr was talking about how heavy he
was drinking how hard he was going and I
had no idea Freddy was going like that
like I mean nothing I thought he was I
thought he was semi healthy I had no
idea he was partying like hardcore you
don't know man you don't know what
[ __ ] people are going through you
know you don't know you gotta keep it
you gotta keep it semi healthy bro you
know I mean semi don't be eating those
[ __ ] short ribs when they put them in
your face all the time they got rid of
the stars Joey show the little starters
a little I don't do that yo Rogan got me
to eat edibles back in the day I don't
touch edibles bro you don't know if
you're getting all the weed and the Ted
of the gummy bear you're gonna which
again I can't you had a bad experience
yeah on this plane and I couldn't get
off yeah I just I just it was just a bad
experiment into full paranoia and body
high I don't like it I like to take my
one bit of the flour that I know what
I'm old-school bro I got a pipe with
weed in it right now yeah I mean you
haven't seen this [ __ ] in 20 years
but I don't I don't do the pens I don't
do the edible [ __ ] I just go old school
give me the buds over here hey 1/8 back
where were you from here Ohio day to
Dayton I'm right between Cincinnati and
Columbus so you got to blow it when I
was you and Joe Rogan it was just you
Joe Rogan and Brian Redman because I
remember him you and he and he would
bring like Duncan's like dogged middle
boom and Joe would do and then sometimes
Joey GaSe would come with us naari
sometimes re you know it was that
rotation and then when Joe and I and
then when I got thrown off the tour it
was the rest of them forever you know
I'm one managable bro I'm hard I don't
know I just don't play the games I don't
play games
I don't play the you know the politics
but also you're writing now you wrote
for Michael Rapaport yeah I wrote so
I've been writing bro along I am
impressed what was I want to write a
book too I got you thank you bro I got I
didn't know you were all like that bro
but I know you were uh I know you were
like when I hear whenever hear the
conversation I was totally sideways it
was Mike yard was a man Mazda brawny
their argument bread earners they were
arguing for days yeah I mean I didn't I
never got in a political [ __ ] but I was
always writing on the side like I've
always been a writer you only been
writer always on the side I was always
trying to sell screenplays you know just
before yeah so I never sold anything but
then luckily I got uh you know they
hired me to do this movie called my man
as a loser that came out you know with
Lionsgate which was starring Rappaport
John Stamos and Bryan Callen so that was
like my first movie they got made and
then they let me direct a movie so I
wrote it directed it you know it was a
five million dollar movie for my first
movie so I was like whoa it was like a
big it was a it was a lot of work I
looked homeless after the [ __ ] was over
like I looked like a disaster a lot of
work but then Rapoport and I became good
friends on that movie and he had a book
deal he had a book offer from Simon &
Schuster and he called me he said you
know would you just would you be with
the ghostwriter for my book and so we
cut a deal
and I ghostwrote his book with him and
his books called my Matt my this book
has balls so it's like really just
Rappaport's rants but I kind of had to
just organize them into a real chat you
know chapter by chapter you know
situation and it ended up being a great
thing man so I love writing honey those
write a book for like people who don't
know like like like like [ __ ] you wrong
class or was it one of those as told to
or so you hung all with him yeah we hung
out every day so every day Rapoport
looks like say Rapoport had an idea for
a chapter say the chapter was about
Muggsy Bogues and like the tape oh and
so the chapter was about why isn't Mugsy
Bogues given TED talks like everyone
wants to talk about who's such a genius
how about a five-foot one dude who had
no chance at the NBA and became a 12
year NBA player let's talk about him so
then he gave that idea to me and then I
turned the chapter into like Mugsy
Bogues from childhood and like kind of
like you know what Mugsy Bogues must
have been like like how cocky and strong
he must have been when like they wanted
him to play in The Wizard of Oz and play
Toto he's like no no no I'm the lion so
I you know Rapoport would have an idea
email it to me I'd start the chapter
send it to him for like an okay and then
he'd be like yo I love that run with it
and then I'd write each chapter and then
the book had to be 75 thousand words but
you know by contract and so we did
chapters on LeBron we did why lawrence
taylor was the greatest football player
of all time cuz every record he said he
was on crack cocaine it was really like
a comedy take on all Rappaport's you
know ideas of and rants so it was just a
process you know and so it's a lot of
work but we would we probably meet up
once a week but every night you know he
basically send me ideas and Rappaport's
got that type of brain that's like not
really linear like that so he'd be like
you know a misspelled sentence of like
you know Muggsy Bogues ted talk he
should do this and then i kind of come
in and just boom make it a full chapter
so you know it's just a discipline and
you know and then after it is so i did
the book and then after my man is a
loser i got lucky
after that and then netflix bought my
movie a stand-up guy so they let me I
wrote and directed and
movie called a stand-up guy it's on
Netflix right now who stars in it I put
Rappaport in that one also but this kid
Danny a who's like in the Irishman
coming up and Danny A's in it Saget I
put in it gave him a cameo and it's
about a it's about a gangster that goes
into the witness protection program I
think I don't know if I told you but
goes into a witness protection program
and on a dare he does an open mic night
in the city that he's hiding in and he's
good at comedy and he gets on an open
mic he kind of starts to blow up in the
small town
the mobs looking for him he gets in a
fight one night on stage it goes viral
on somebody's phone get took a million
hits and the [ __ ] mob is on him so he
has to come back obviously the Brooklyn
and like testify and I mean I you know
it goes they don't kill him I'll tell
you the ending [ __ ] it's better than
efforts for a year and a half if you
haven't seen it yet go see it but uh you
know so the guys come after him and then
they do not kill him he gets to do the
Tonight Show as like the last beep you
know he's like a rising comedy star so
it was just a cool it was an idea that I
got when that [ __ ] went down with me I
was like I got to write something
inspired by this so I was like head I
always had to thought like if I had to
go into like you ever had to go into
witness protection what are you gonna
just stop being funny ya know you're
gonna be the funniest dude in that
little tiny town and so that's where I
got the idea and then that was my second
movie writing and directing and then
yeah man I got a you know then I just
sold another one that lion's gates gonna
do called the district it's a drama so
I've been writing bro like I'm still
doing my stand-up strong like trying to
keep my both brains going but to me it's
like the same thing it's like stant you
you write your stand up right now right
your stand up but this is just I'm just
like you know discipline with the
writing and I love it I love writing you
know just as much almost as much as I
love doing stand-up so I'm keeping them
both going you like writing Miller you
do stand-up Johnny I let both I like
Stan because I get that instant really
like response by like writing because I
can control the world right if I want to
kill somebody in a script I do it
exactly exactly it's a safe place to
live out your murder
yeah no but it's true but what I like
about writing is that like you'd write
and when you get in that zone boom you
look up and it's like three hours are
gone that's like that that's the [ __ ] I
like it's like you really put in work
but you didn't even see it was like
almost like your unconscious is just
working so you know I'm writing and I'm
like you know developing stuff you know
writing stuff for other like comedians
and you know whatever I got a movie idea
for us bro
I got some I got so alright I got
something you ready you're working right
now well sure with Bob Saget right I saw
yeah I wrote yeah I wrote on Saget's new
show is called videos after dark so it's
like a edgy version of what he used to
do with like the video show you know
America's Funniest Videos but it's like
a late-night sexy version so I wrote
that thank you for Saget it's like yeah
a video that woman who Batman put in his
hand and will be the ass and they have
it as money yeah
stuff like that by the way [ __ ] I didn't
laugh it when I was growing up you know
listen I'll be real like I didn't if you
ever fell down and got hurt you really
don't laugh at people falling down
getting hurt because you're like oh [ __ ]
that's a concussion that's 40 stitches
like you know what it is but it was
great because the show it's called
videos after dark and we premiered last
Tuesday after the bachelor finale oh
yeah
so now they're gonna move us to a 10
o'clock spot and it'll be on and on the
right of Rome one of the writers me
Saget and this guy Michael O'Rourke
who's like another writer you know and
uh you know I'm I like writing at home
alone more than I like being in that
writers room you know cuz you just catch
a cold
yeah I mean you're in that awful [ __ ]
I'm not an office guy like sack it's
always like here why are you always
pacing around oh my god I can't sit
still like I don't sit still do you type
on a computer you write it both look if
I like Mike like my comedy out like you
know go right to a pad like a legal pad
I mean but then I transfer it over to
the computer and and just do it that way
you know so I'm computer now well do all
right that [ __ ] low right
paper yeah are you writing you you write
movie stuff or just whatever yeah
hooking stories it's like I tell anybody
man like people asked me about like
making movies or whatever I always say
this it's like you got an idea at this
point it doesn't cost anything to go
shoot something so it's like yo don't
let somebody else tell you what you're
funny shit's gonna be just go get your
boys with a camera go shoot it you know
I mean on your own and go edit it on
your own or with one of your friends who
knows how to edit and then nobody can
say like I got a great idea for you you
know you go here this is my idea this is
the show that I want to do hand it over
and if they like it they like it you
know you guys just take control like
that yeah that show gente fide though it
was a web series lasted about two years
now Netflix picked it up and it's a
series but it started from nothing
it was started from some people wanted
to put Boyle Heights in a show and
Latinos yeah you know same with high
maintenance high maintenance was a
ten-minute thing that was running HBO
picked it up for a half-hour show and
then you know I did this thing I should
just say I shot a pilot called single
Mike right I shot this little 10-minute
sizzle reel like three years ago single
it like based on my life navigating
single in LA you know what I mean like
my r-rated Seinfeld dream and I shot it
and I was like I love what I shot it was
kind of sitting around I showed it to
like five six of my boys that were in
the business either directors or
whatever and every few months my boys
were calling oh yeah what's going on
with that and so finally enough people
that I respected like asked me you know
what was going on with it I was like you
know what maybe I need to go shoot this
for real and so I went and like goddess
I got an investor and shot the pilot and
we just shot it and like you know
brought in some real you know real
actors and real you know real think I
got the DP from shameless you know I
mean that my boy katha pollitt reinvest
I got to gangster you know I mean I had
to flip it on him I'm not telling my new
bro but you know what you could do kind
of check for 200 but how long do it on
your own how hard is it to get money we
don't know nobody hopefully you know
nobody have a movie idea you ready to
call me
I'll tell you this you're not getting
money on an idea only I think you need
to do at least write the script and then
you go out there's a real or do a sizzle
reel and go get the money
I did a sizzle reel I'd gave it to a
couple investment type of dudes that I
knew who like respected the comedy and I
got the money you know just because they
loved the sizzle I feel like treatments
don't even get the idea across anymore
don't want to read it you know well not
just that it's like they can't visualize
what you're trying to do I'm sure you
got ideas for yourself bro I know people
are probably talking right now okay your
development with production company yeah
yeah well you hold on to like hold on to
your thing like whatever you know your
thing is like don't let somebody come in
and be like I want you to articulate
every single word no bro
nah man you're funny thank you you know
you're funny that's the beautiful thing
about stand-up is that like science you
go out there you say what you say they
laugh it's a guaranteed done deal
you can't have an executive or anybody
tell you like I think this will be
funnier none I did in front of a
thousand people it's proven so right
because those executives they have their
ideas that are safe what what the trends
are who's doing what but they don't
they're so scared to take risk a risk
I'm gonna do a leather version of what
the last guy did I know they do because
they feel always the word and the [ __ ]
never works
you mean what works is when you disrupt
the harmony of what's going on and like
when Friday came out 30 shitty
Friday movies came out exactly and
probably three TV shows and then when
Pope friction came out a thousand shitty
Pope fishing with him on exactly mother
get Boondock Saints but it came out the
same year - yeah but that's a coke class
a type anymore Emily bomb Boondock
Saints yeah so for years I just saw that
the other day what made you say because
I see motive yeah I love Boondock Saints
it's a weird you know that's wasn't his
biggest room our morning yeah exactly
really good Bob Marley he's in part -
yeah so stupid with Willem to focus
about what happened this guy takes four
- we came out of there the last guy
yeah shut this guy like this way he shut
the whole see bro he we ma'am
you wish that the buckets over the crowd
with that easy bro Willem Dafoe man he's
a freaky he's just a few better I never
met her
Gary Busey madam so we were ready for
the roast I have not written for the
roast no I don't know how I don't know
if roasting is my thing like I need to I
don't know man everything every rose
don't want to write I want to keep
exactly like I might need it what yeah
like I could I don't know man I've never
been a roaster I've never been good at
like the negative bearing somebody just
bashing that's never been like my style
of comedy you know what do you got there
questions asking a job advice to the
other really asking is can i [ __ ] you
know the last job I had I was fired a
week ago but the last two I was laid out
most likely for performance issues my
bro
Cooper Wilkinson wrote a book about why
I get fired you should listen to all the
reasons you've gotten fired and maybe
write a book about why I get fired and
why I don't do well in life that should
be a book yeah it's a pamphlet that work
if you like writing [ __ ] all these
sentences on YouTube write a book might
as well know somebody wants to read it
out there a hundred percent even if even
if your name is Jose the dirty carpenter
you're a carpenter but you always like
take write write down whatever stupid
thing you got you're fired
what happened bro all right I'll lay
some pipe I started giggling who they
were all we're men and then there we go
there's a market for their drink orders
could I eat on the shrimp there's a
market for it all bro write it down
write all your firings people are asking
you why you don't do the Comedy Store as
much anymore you know I appreciate that
question I got beef you know I told you
already gun I'm a disruptive person what
do you say we had a Minuteman and he
said he can't go up sometimes yeah and
like I'm the old crew cat huh it's like
like my boys are going up you know my
boy there's politics oh I get it like if
you're famous go ahead
always tell me to call anything man I
don't want to call it I think someone
else's pot I'm working every week no but
I listen I'm not just stroking my ego
I'm like yo bro I'm working a lot
I'll give me my damn spot and a decent
time and if you don't believe me go put
me in the middle of all the bangers like
let's see how I do you want to see like
let's go you want to put me after
Sebastian me you want to put me after
Joey Diaz put me after Joey Diaz and
I'll those are my people
let's let's see but like that like
you're having to prove yourself again to
this Newark no there's some other weird
thing man I don't know if it's some
other weird [ __ ] but like I don't I try
not to take it personally
right because I'll get like the every
now and then I'll get like that later
spot but it's like I got a real 12 yeah
like a 12 12 15 12 and it's like you
know I'm like I'm the cusp of like I
just [ __ ] smack the manager you know
I got that in me like but I have but I
would not do you have to unleash bro you
know I mean and by the way I think Mitzi
would be proud if I like more just
smacked Adam like just sorry you know I
don't give a [ __ ] because but I you know
what am I guess one of the greatest I
can't get mad about it cuz there's no
one to get mad at anyone there there's
no one to get mad know who's who
but there's no like rhyme or reason you
know but whatever it is I don't get it
as many spots as I used to get and I
wish I did because I'm in town for
whatever I'm in town I love the Comedy
Store but if you know they're not gonna
put me up what can I say I do I do Obama
some Tripoli shows yeah you get invited
to the little show yeah and I do the
college shows back yeah Skyler's stone
yeah I love Tripoli
but like and and by the way the place -
huh any [ __ ] that I've done I'm never
with anybody or for anybody you get
robbed by a hooker - yeah but not
recently but back in the days after yes
let me tell you - yeah Tripoli so
remember when I had a young American
tour twice do you remember what I had
the young American comedy thing yeah
yeah 1012 years ago yeah no but I put my
boys on it
I made up a [ __ ] tour bro out of this
yeah yeah I don't even know you did that
yes the young Americans back in a day a
lot of people get amnesia yeah I own I
made it up on this on the patio of the
car yo this is my Jewish brain working
right so so somebody tells me like the
Kings of Comedy made 16 million dollars
and I was like oh with Bernie Mac and
all those guys and we were this 12 years
ago so we're all just like coming up but
we're funny so I'm thinking on the
comedy store patio I'm looking at
Sebastian and Brett and Bobby Lee and
Tony rock and I'm literally
Triple E and I see Triple E and I'm
thinking well if they made 16 million
dollars we got at least 3 million worth
of funny on the patio at the same time
you said that
slowly Joey Medina and he came in he
said Jamie Foxx at lappa falooda [ __ ]
I'll do let you Palooza did it yeah so I
did it right so I put Triple E on and
Bobby Lee we to me young American
character we did it for three years but
then I wasn't like business savvy enough
to like know what was going on in like
the improv chain they kind of came at me
like like gangster style and and the and
Robert Hartman was like do you own this
like you own the tour and I did I owned
it I've paint franchise tax you know I
created the name and got a website I did
the whole thing and so what he was
really trying to say was can I own half
your [ __ ] and we'll keep booking you so
they booked us for like three years but
after that meeting with them they shut
us down but we just never got booked
again and I wasn't I didn't know the
game enough I just had no manager doing
it I was one of them or one it was you
know what damn bird
Robert Hartman one he wanted like either
a piece of it like he wanted to own half
of it or only TV he's coming in and
buying up the mom-and-pop shop and
saying or partnering with them and then
just shutting him out of business
yeah and by the way I would have given
him the part of the tour but I put
Tripoli on the tour and we did a bunch
he did a bunch of cities with us we had
a great time but then when he started
doing his show at the laughs at The
Comedy Store I'm like yo Sam if there's
any Annie you know you got any openings
I'm in town for a while I love
your show and you know he just you just
forgot you know I mean and it's like I
never I didn't do the young American
tour so that five eight that twelve
years later I could be like put me at
first spot but it's like [ __ ]
just forget bro Schuyler stolen he's
your boy here my boy let me tell you
something he has Alzheimer's everybody -
from here I got no beef with him but one
day I don't even know him really at all
like I kind of know him from the
whatever from the comedy I'm actually
I'm on the road with Saget I'm and then
we're in the middle of nowhere I get a
text from him I don't even know how he
got my number
go throw me off bro he texts me oh my
what he's like my kid loves Saget my kid
loves SEC can you have Saget do a video
for my kids oh my god I know so I just
like say to sag they say that that's my
boy which is not my boy but I say Bob
would you mind doing like a happy
birthday to this kid of course Saget
does it I send it to Skyler I don't
think anything of it right a month later
I see that he's doing like a rock and
roll comedy night the caller stuff
yo so I'm like yo bro if you got any
spots I'd love to do your show this is
in like June he go he like he's like oh
yeah no problem I got an opening in
April six months later [ __ ] you
got an opening in April
it's just a spot and by the way I didn't
do sag it's think so I get I don't even
know you had a room but like I live by a
code
Felipe alright if you do something like
that
remember I unwritten rules yeah
unwritten rule bro Felipe you do a happy
birthday to my nephew you know I mean no
I see you that's uncomfortable though
yeah before the show started YouTube an
exam is it right up front could you give
me a bottle yes by the way and by the
way yeah and Saget he really didn't want
to do it helm but I had to double ask
him I double asked I think of how to ask
you I asked
rappers massage so I asked this kid I
asked this guy do you mind if I go up on
one of your nights like I'm thinking oh
yeah next week the week after cool April
so I don't say [ __ ] to him but I did but
then it's like it's bothering me it's
easy it's easier no sir just this month
it's Bob
on April spam it's bothering me so like
a month later after he tells me I can go
up in five months six months I said
listen bro I gotta be honest you you you
have no code that you live by like you
got no integrity I said you don't have
any principle what are you talking about
what I said I didn't do the Bob Saget
thing so I could get on your rock and
roll comedy [ __ ] you know I mean I said
I didn't even know you did a room I said
but when I asked you to do it yeah
you're gonna tell me that I could go up
in six months I said you just don't have
any [ __ ] backbone you bug-eyed
[ __ ] you paid for everything for
chapo basic oh yeah always treat him you
always booked him on shows and then you
ask him for a cup of coffee and he says
no I'm worried about coffee just get it
reach it what did you get notified bro
give me a coffee you have money
exactly like I'm asking you for a kidney
he didn't get so that's gonna affect
your relationship a long time you see
what happened to me when I stopped
grappling but they don't have but to
this day he's gonna [ __ ] to the get in
still I'm the bad guy isn't that
interesting that that's how he would
think that you're the bad guy it's crazy
and by the way I don't like to talk [ __ ]
but like but that man are you bro by the
way how do you feel and I asked a couple
comedians before I approached him I was
like am I wrong like am i maybe I'm
crazy and then a couple comics right no
no you got to just say something yeah
everybody did a keyboard warrior now
yeah I don't know I died anymore
I went I went I die harder at first but
yeah it's better yo the air is clear
mute listen dude I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody in person
yeah it's harder at first but in the end
it's the better thing to do yo and I see
him at the store it's all like I'm not
gonna when we're done talking like
there's nothing there's nothing to talk
about anymore but I had to get off my
chest it was one of those things I was
like I'm gonna just get uncomfortable
it's not comfortable for me I'm not a
good communicator and you get ulcers
dogs yeah I was like let me let this one
go and so but that but but I was like am
I crazy or like somebody does that for
you you just put me up bro
like you're next you're not on the flyer
all those tools that you owe you have
always throwing bows but they don't have
both to throw but they keep whining bone
for the rest of their lives right that's
a change my brakes people - yeah that's
a whole different thing where somebody
who did book you in the past they're
asking you for what I don't like it an
open book doesn't move do commoner no
more who happens to live now we're doing
stand-up comedy now any hits you up an
hour before the show that's funny as
hell because that's are those we may do
there's like a dude in Denver that you
knew back in this I really wanted to you
size up at the county you know what city
he lives in you know you're in a city
you didn't want to answer the [ __ ]
you don't know open it up so true and
why would you even show up even if they
didn't open up your [ __ ] little
[ __ ] message that is so true no
course I hate when a comic is your show
already or is Bob Saget show but there's
a comic who lives in our lane who ever
lived in a river but he wants to impress
them or manager that week to get booked
but he wants to do a guest spot and
you're like bro come on man I can't so
here come football ready it's not my
club I can't do you mean I can't
you know you know that most of these
people who ask for this won't shut up
either doesn't do all the yapping in the
green room right prime rib because you
feel a comfortable road here that head
lightning and there's a yapper there you
know who the headlight doesn't even know
was mad on you dude and by the way it
lets you know that like there's just not
that many funny people in the world I
know my like yo bro you have to move out
of LA
you're not funny in Denver he ain't
gonna be funny if you go to Chicago
you're just gonna [ __ ] our show up we
had a comedian working with us and then
he had a friend that showed up all right
he was in a green room all right for one
night but there wasn't a Ford or a steak
and I said man you better not come here
tomorrow don't you show up we were
staying but up from the city I don't
give a [ __ ] Toby Higgs spin it now your
house antenna there I didn't spend a
night over there I know you are your
lady didn't suck my dick on stage does
not accept anything I know man that's
why I say no to all t-shirts anybody
wants to bring you ice won't bring you a
t-shirt that guy threw a t-shirt on you
in the meet-and-greet you're wearing a
shirt you got a navigate bro and you're
you know you're you're you're only
getting bigger and stronger so you just
you keep doing it the right way and just
you know me say no to the dude in the
Denver funny way home telling you all
your buddy how to eat you up yeah yeah
always put like my hometown I don't
they're not hitting me up for spots
they're looking for free take yeah so
I'll hook that up like you know
obviously my got a big family back there
some friends I haven't seen in a while
so that that I don't mind so much
you mean so like the friends in my
hometown you know I only got four Ville
so it's all good party you know I don't
know do you member I still do the bit
about having a criminal friend you
remember no one I like those the one the
Hennessy the I'll still bring that out
of the phone if I see a Hennessy go down
it's going I don't like the war we did
about the one about I still laugh in the
back and the one about our row plane or
roller skates or something no no no
you're thinking of brenards roller
skates and scrunch oh yeah
so this was the roller skate bit he
doesn't put him on yeah I was gonna say
my have a good one of my boys was a
straight criminal that I grew up with
you know in and out and just he lives
that life but the one time I brought him
we did the young American comedy tour at
the Royal Oak music Peter and a big
theater a nice venue I see him first
time in a long time
this [ __ ] Rob's empty like a
cash register he robbed my own show
he basically run not the whole show but
he got a hold of like one of the cash
registers or whatever near the bar and
he's robbed me my mom me my bucharest
dad he was laughing about letting you
know i never changed what was praised my
friends robbed my old van just grabbed
it right so you know why boy rick i do i
do i no white boy no a father you know
him I know him well mother things in huh
yeah me and Rick right this is a mate
yep so but growing up in middle school
he was famous like he knew white boy
Rick when he was free like we knew who
he was he would be like the white boy
you know fur coat with a gold chain
going across the during recess but long
story well people really selling guns
that much in that city hell yeah in the
eighties when crack hit his dad was a
major gun runner so his dad was one of
gun shows he would get him from the gun
shows he was the he was known to have
the best guns for the best price but he
started selling them to killers and dope
dealers and he didn't know who he was a
dad he didn't know who he was really
selling to and then when the feds can't
you know they were already looking at
him when the feds came down on the dad
boom the dad had Rick Jew you know had
his son with him at a like a launch or
whatever and he the feds were showing
you know showing the dad pictures of you
know these gangsters and they're like
who's this and the dads like I don't
know but Rick was like yo that's Butch
Jones the head of the young boys
incorporated that's so-and-so you know
so the you know you saw the movie if you
saw the movie you know the story was the
feds start paying him when he's 14 years
old but the way I know him well the way
I really know him is I was doing I wrote
a drama that was set in Detroit in the
70s and I hired a criminal research dude
and so the
research dude was always talking to Rick
from other stuff like from articles and
whatever and one day Rick called while
we were at dinner and he put me on the
phone with him so we started this before
the movie came out and so we started
talking on the phone while we you know
while he's locked up and turns out you
know he knows people in Hollywood
because like you know Scott silver wrote
the movie and Scott Franklin produced it
and you know it's a big movie Matthew
McConaughey's stars in the his manner
right yeah
what's that as a dad in the movie yeah
Mike on he plays is dead yep so so we
start talking and he's like yo bro you
know we signed up on my prison thing so
that I could call you whenever I want to
talk to you about some things so long
story short he asked me if I would write
his book when his book he wanted to do a
book so he knew I did Rappaport's book
he knew I was a writer we got along on
the phone and he asked me if I would do
his book and I said hell yeah if we get
a real deal you know after you know cuz
he's supposed to get out like in the
next 16 months he's done 30 years
already so when he gets out he wants me
to do his book so we talk every week but
the cut you know that obviously is a
comedian there's comedy and all this
[ __ ] so like you know like when his
movie was going down he's like my first
movie that I did was financed by Dan
Gilbert who owns the Cleveland Cavaliers
yeah he owns the Cavs so he put up all
the money so he asked me because they
shot white boy Rick in Cleveland they
shot most of it in Cleveland even though
set in Detroit they had to shoot it in
Cleveland for tax incentive but Rick was
like yo bro can you get um McConaughey
front-row seats I was like yo bro here's
how were the world works on the outside
like Matthew McConaughey doesn't need me
[ __ ] Mike Young the comedian to get
him tickets to the Cavs game he can just
basically call the owner probably Dan
Gilbert and he can get tickets and so
like he don't need me
Makani doesn't need me so next thing you
know McConaughey you know you turn on
the TV there's McConaughey's sitting
front row at the Cavs game next to Dan
Gilbert but you know through this whole
thing Rick and I have like remained
friends and I'm gonna do his book when
he gets out and so you know it'll be a
big job it should be a big book you
never know like it's a crazy story he's
already told me wild [ __ ] beyond Wow
[ __ ] bro III and it's it's public
knowledge so I could tell you like the
feds are paying him at 14 years old they
put him in the game right so they're
giving him money make a buy here tell us
who's who
bah-bah-bah he's with them for you know
till he's 17 years old 14 to 17 he's an
informant so when he's 15 he's making
moves on his own now he's not telling
the feds everything he's making deals
he's selling kilos on his own he's
making real money and trying to do it on
the low by the time he's 16 the feds
Allah and they're doing real [ __ ] with
him and like here's $2,000 here's $2,000
we got you a ticket to the hurons Hagler
fight in Vegas you're gonna go to the
fight in Vegas and you're gonna come
back and you're gonna tell us who the
Detroit Miami connection is because you
know how the dope dealers go to major
fights so all the Detroit guys were
going out there they're gonna meet there
connect he was supposed to come back but
he goes out there he's a kid he's
[ __ ] 16 years old at the time he goes
out there he ends up like sleeping with
hookers doing drugs gonna be he doesn't
tell anybody he gets no information it
goes to the fight you know Nemean hangs
out at the after parties had the best
time ever comes back I don't think your
brain is fully settled as a kid until
you're in your total eight 20s it's just
a fact you're a dude we're even later so
in his mind he's really [ __ ] thinking
he's living a movie like he's just
living it he's got ten thousand in the
pocket out at all times and
unfortunately he didn't get the memo
when the feds were like yo bro we're
done with you quit dealing drugs we
already know what you're doing it's just
doing the crime continuing the crime
then we kept the crime going so when
they eventually he's 17 years old they
catch him [ __ ] coming home one night
they they got the tip from a cop dirty
cop and they they find Stiga he's got
seven kilos of cocaine in the trunk and
they [ __ ] find him they lock him up
and next thing you know he goes to trial
and he's got the gangster lawyer
high-powered lawyer and he thinks that
because of the situation he was in he's
gonna get off or he's gonna get
probation is a minor yeah no it was the
Michigan
it was the lifer lifer law so if you had
over 350 grams of cocaine you were life
without parole
that was it back then you got life
without parole so they [ __ ] gave him
life without parole
when white privilege backfires and he
wasn't white privilege he was poor white
trash he was [ __ ] poor he grew up in
the hood in Detroit
his dad was advancing an example of him
an example but they really locked him
why so much cuz they didn't catch all
those other fools not just well not just
that he had the dirt on everybody so in
Detroit in the eighties everybody was
dirty the mayor the mayor the Chief of
Police
yo remember the movie you know Beverly
Hills Cop Gil Hill who played the
detective the Chief of Police we had
against Eddie Murphy that was in the
movie that was the real that was a real
Gil Hill that played that part oh really
they got him on a federal wiretap except
in like 50,000 in a in a you know to
cover up some crime like I saw the
[ __ ] I saw the video he's like kill
he'll factor he and they indicted him he
ended up in Seoul yeah exactly
he was buried here why he was corrupt
bro you look good actor though he was
young he was dead that was no that was
the chief of police Farina
yeah he was the real chief of all that
and it was dirty eighth grade principal
yeah yeah and so they were locked they
gave Ric life because he had the dirt on
everybody put forty cops away I mean you
know the dude that tried to kill him the
assassin that was hired to kill him who
shot him and missed but had 25 bodies on
him as a hired killer anyway he ended up
getting out in 16 years he got 16 years
Rick I got the most of every Rick got
the most Rick was in federal prison one
day in walks the guy that tried to kill
him
that Rick's like oh [ __ ] here comes the
[ __ ] you know Nate boom craft is his
name he's public knowledge and I was
like so I said to Rick when I was doing
you know starting to craft like just
some like beat beats of the mood of the
book I was like what was that like when
the kid got they tried to kill you came
in to jail and he's just like cool about
he's just like yo man we ain't we walked
we talked it out we were like yo we were
both young we were in the game this is
what it was and it wasn't his personal
desire to kill this guy it was a job
yeah it was a job it was always a job
for that guy it was never personal with
him this dude was a straight
work-for-hire and he was anybody missed
Rick and he taught the way he talked
about it he was like he's like man I
tried to get him out
he's like I was on the rooftop he went
he went in the other entrance he's like
I was gonna get him on the day of his
court date he was like I had my scope
right II I was on the building he's like
he decided to go around back
I couldn't believe it man [ __ ] missed
up like talking about it you know no
that's all [ __ ] in the movie
[ __ ] he did have it but it was only
for like under a year okay in the movie
that's another thing in the movie I felt
like he just cleared it up for me right
there because I was like cool why I I
thought the drugs that he was found with
were actually given to him for the job
you know to me but it was him continuing
the crime he was doing I don't think
that was made clear made you feel more
like these detectives all turned on I'm
sure they were corrupt but I don't they
didn't give it to him and then set him
up and then arrest exactly and that's
why the movie really it didn't do that
well I was because he just yeah it was a
confusing man the director was like from
Europe like he's like a European
director who's like dope with like the
visual [ __ ] but like you gotta be a you
know you gotta have some Street
knowledge Leicester Square me you know
it wasn't it wasn't the movie that it
should have been cuz his story was
foolin Anna it looked better than it
actually was
right it was it was his stories where
the maids are Matthew McConaughey
gangster too huh yeah they made him gay
dad was less involved yeah homeboy
started making mad money you gotta work
for he were the family reformed right
sister up the street and they made him
like look like the the real truth is he
was never like a kingpin dope dealer
they tried to make him like a king right
he was always a mid to low level in at
the time in Detroit when they was around
I mean Butch Jones who was the head of
the YBI which was the young boys
incorporated who and and Cliff Jones was
all the woman for them but the chambers
did you know about them so the Chambers
Brothers they were real kid when they
were around I was a little kid but my
mom taught well that's a tease right
yeah yeah but my mom was a public
schoolteacher in Detroit like right
outside Detroit in Southfield chamber
brothers so my mom had students that
were connected to all those guys you
know and she would like know about those
guys and
you know she was its she taught some
real bad dudes and so we just always
knew about those guys but the Chambers
Brothers you know they were you know the
first big-time dope dealers in the city
and they they went against the gangster
like there was like the young boys
incorporated was the biggest organized
gang you know but the Chambers Brothers
were their own gang and they came from
the south so like the movie
Denzel movie lacking gangster that was
based on the Chambers Brothers that was
based on the dudes that really were they
were in Detroit they changed it in the
movie I don't know where they were from
yeah but that was the inspiration for
those guys but they got caught because
they were just so [ __ ] flashy and
they're taking pictures of them with
cash money and like we're gonna give
these singles to the homeless you know
be on video but giving away turkeys but
to put the dope dealing in Detroit it
was the worst city at the time it cuz
crack came in and that was it was gone
around the same time a little bit later
right after that yeah the auto industry
had plummeted yeah ever for GM they all
went down and they are and and Detroit
was just a disaster and it went into the
tank when you were a major major when
you were a kid growing up did you saw
the change immediately
oh you're your parents are anymore my
mom's saw it big time she saw kids on
crack she saw [ __ ] so like I was in I
grew up in Southfield which is like a
mixed community and then like the kids
from Detroit had the opportunity had the
chance to get bused to my school so like
in eighth grade it was like a wave of
you know black kids and and seven-mile
like a Rams like all of a sudden boom we
call them a revs cuz that's just how we
roll like that's just they were my lot
they're my boys like but that's just
kind of out of that's how they talked
about each other like that's just how
you talk they're actually called
Chaldean is like the real they were a
Christian sect from Iraq that started
coming to Detroit and opening liquor
stores and stuff like that you know so
they were the first kids I saw was like
you know knots of cash in like middle
school turn the water to wine literally
and so my school became like a super
mixed diverse school like Hollywood you
want to talk about diversity don't
[ __ ] tell me about diversity bro I'll
[ __ ] send you back to my locker
partner
we had real diversity in Detroit back
then so it was but you saw that when the
crack [ __ ] hit it was like boom [ __ ]
changed like immediately people were
getting [ __ ] killed in closed areas
and I was in the suburbs even I mean but
my dad well you know we were
working-class and then my dad made a
little more money when I got older and
like kind of got us out of the one
neighborhood into like a more the
upper-middle class situation but for a
long time bro the first neighborhood I
was in was that type of white trash that
you saw in the outsiders like you think
that's just a movie those real [ __ ]
white people with leather jackets and
guns like I didn't even like I was and
they hated me there's a murder in San
Bernardino dude yeah exactly that type
of [ __ ] I saw that as a kid and we're
like the only Jewish man we were like
the only Jewish family on the block but
I saw like I saw a lot of [ __ ] as a kid
because my dad I mean just full
disclosure he passed away when he was
young very young but my dad saw my dad
used to run in all men's is gonna sound
ridiculous but my dad used to run like
an all men's health club and the Detroit
mob this is what the this how this was
the drama that I wrote yeah for real
she knows so so this is how this was the
drama I was working on when Rick got
ahold of me but my dad used to run a
place called the Southfield Athletic
Club and the Mafia in the Detroit mafia
that was their headquarters like the
heads of the mob they would work out
there takes teams all that to try Cronk
boxing Tommy Hearns you know Hilmer Kent
date all the chronic boxers that were
champions they would work out there and
it was kind of like a meet like a center
place and my dad was like making no
money but he was like running the place
and he was looking just like a trusted
guy like my dad was not a gangster at
all he was just a middleman type of
person who just don't get they just
liked him he was a likable duty played
racquetball he would set it up so like
as a little kid me my brother would be
running around this place and this was
the place that if you if you Google saw
you know Southfield Athletic Club it
will come up like American Mafia calm
and when Jimmy Hoffa disappeared in 1975
everybody's alibi was that they were
taken esteem did it
you know at this software that let it
cook so I used to joke about like I'd be
like I think Hoffa disappeared in my
grandpa's car but but that was the place
that like the Hoffa disappearance that
was the one centerpiece that everybody
knew because you know whoever would
allegedly kill Hoffa they think it was
you know the Irishman the movie that's
coming out with Scorsese Frank Sheeran
you know basically said he killed Hoff
on his deathbed but he was in Detroit it
was a Purple Gang out of Detroit that's
out of Detroit the original that's real
they were bootleggers brought the
original Purple Gang out of Detroit
they were the joy of mafia brought it
Cleveland - I love the you know I wrote
the book bro yeah look so the Purple
Gang so the Kewell family I was like the
head of that [ __ ] you know they were
devastated
gangsters like real bad they call them
out to do to New York to go take care of
[ __ ] they call them to Chicago to take
care of [ __ ] but they were the Purple
Gang they called him that because they
were young and they had [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] flush faces look at purple kids
in the cold so that's where they got
their name but the Purple Gang boom then
became the Detroit mob and the Detroit
mafia was super powerful because even
though they didn't have like a seat on
the five families the Commission they
still had like they still got major
respect because they ran you know scrap
metal and trucking and you know the auto
industry they had a hand in everything
so if you like to look back at like you
know Henry Ford jr. there was always
like another guy that was like
second-in-command who like those
children of strikes he was controlling
the strike they forgot his name he was
like but but he Ford gave him the job
and he would just run where he would
start his own [ __ ] dealership he
would do it everywhere he had the run of
the mill because he the gangsters ran
[ __ ] you know I mean and my dad was just
like a [ __ ] like in the middle of all
this [ __ ] and growing up my brother and
I were just lucky enough to see like
really cool [ __ ] like champion boxing
matches when we were like 10 years old
my gender ray sugar ray Tommy Hearns you
know I mean Duran that whole era my dad
was like taking the family to Vegas for
a hundred bucks like we didn't have to
pay and so you know
I don't know how deep you want to go in
the story but like I'd be like 12 years
old in a four bedroom suite at Caesar's
Palace you know and like me and my
brother would be like giddy kids I smoke
a cigar I mean yo I Kris mocha cigars
when I was a lad boy bike you know but
like we saw some really cool [ __ ] so my
whole life I kept my brother would
always be like you got to tell this
story about like the club and so finally
I just like you know for like five
months I dedicated myself just to look
to writing this drama and so I mapped it
out I wrote it out and mmm and Paul
Rosenberg his manager came on board is
just as producers so like we haven't
sold it we haven't taken it out yet but
it's that's what it's about that era and
I gotta like fictionalized some things
because you know still people some
people are still alive but I also got a
fictionalised like my dad's type of
character because my dad really was just
a good dude who like eventually went
into scrap metal and like because of his
relationships they let him fly and make
money and my dad just was making cash
like just cash money and I probably have
to like change his character to make him
more of a dangerous type person to
[ __ ] sell it to a new like networks
are like is he a killer but a nice guy
they want Breaking Bad type of [ __ ] and
I couldn't wrap my head around it
because my dad was just like a really
super nice cool dude he wasn't didn't
have it like that but I'll fictionalize
something and take it to the next level
but we saw some [ __ ] bro like you know
when my dad passed away I me and my
brother still got his friends with like
you know Tate look out you know call us
make sure we're all right and so like
when I was like 19 I went to Vegas and
my dad's one of my dad's friends and I
was I was gonna call the drama like the
scrap man the doctor and the gangster
cuz my dad's best friend was a doctor
who was like the gangster he was like
the doctor for like the fighters and the
athletes and entertainers and his other
boy was kind of like this underworld
type figure who owned like massage
parlors on eight mile you know I mean
like he had places like that and we
never really asked what he did but like
when I was 19 we go to Vegas and me and
my brother and he would just like give
us like this card maybe like this is for
your food and
whatever you want to take this and you
eat whatever you want and I mean you
should call it stories from the
Southfield Athletic Club yeah I mean a
lot of people came through there but you
know we were fortunate and uh you know
we were unfortunate that my dad died
young but we were fortunate to see a lot
of [ __ ] in a short period of time at a
you know Detroit had light it was like
lightning in a bottle at that moment you
know to think that like pathi the
biggest murder mystery in American
history basically the connecting tissue
was this place the Southfield Athletic
Club and it was you know very you knew
you were at something that was just like
a different thing no serious actually
you said Purple Gang okay so you know
the Phoenix Suns for a while they used
that as their nickname back in the day
because their colors were purple so my
brother one day is like running around
the Athletic Club in a Phoenix Suns
Purple Gang Chasez Purple Gang but my
brother's just a kid with a Phoenix Suns
Jersey and he runs into like one of the
heads of the you know guys he's oh gee
who's like a you know older man at the
time and he takes my brother and he's
like where's your father
let's go to your father's office and he
walks us to my dad's office at the club
he's like Sam tell your kid to take the
shirt off my brother had to [ __ ]
gave my brother a [ __ ] sweaty ass
racquetball shirt you have danced with
yeah I do I got some dates coming up I
got a so April April 13th I'm at the
PlayStation Theatre in New York with
Saget oh yeah PlayStation theatres April
11th April 11th I'm at The Count Basie
Theatre in Jersey and so we're doing a
Bob and I have like 12 shows in the
Northeast so we're doing Count Basie
Theatre then we're doing PlayStation
Theatre on the 13th then we're doing a
Rutland Vermont whatever theaters up
there we're doing New Hampshire we're
doing all that so if you if you're up in
the Northeast area
Saget and I are coming we're coming
starting in April and you know that want
a hot tub with him no hot tub no Bob is
one of the coolest dude like he gets up
when he doesn't need to have lunch
me guys a grown-ass man he's got three
kids he's got a wife he don't need me is
a long time yeah and so do I politics me
and my beers I'll be in Charlotte North
Carolina this weekend April 4th were
staying at the comedy zone Riverside
April 9 at life Arts Center Spanish or
viva los zetas San Diego April 13 at the
comedy palace Gold Room or Spanish show
with rivet aureus Martin Rizzo and Benjy
and Louise hello
Aloha Sotelo so como Washington April 18
through 20 at that of coma comedy club
Albuquerque New Mexico April 27 at the
Ysleta Resort Casino for the end of the
year was Joe Instagram or Twitter
Instagram at the real Mike Young and we
can review that movie with a movie a
movie a Netflix just call that my box
color played do that it's called a
stand-up guy that's on Netflix my other
movies called my man is a loser which is
on our you know see I know before every
[ __ ] you Terry go do a show or tell
pictures so Marilyn I never work on it's
time for the only comedy - all right for
the only movie show well there's a way
that we get the run actually corners
about I can't be the comedian I said
calm and I we always say but listen man
that's his version I'm a Latino never
been a guy who's a Latino comedian who
has a show and it's just a comedian
absolutely we get always whenever we sit
to pitch something about the weed yeah
well the first one was we pitched a show
years ago executive it was your manager
at the time yo bro I'll write you a hit
you caught my girl wanted to do a show
before there were any others we wanted
to do a show about two guys who like
kind of like clerks but who worked in a
weed shop this was seven years ago
eight
how long have I been your manager eight
years seven years seven so variety job
well it's been anyway so he said he said
well they wouldn't care about don't know
about weed as a subject for a whole show
people aren't really doing that and it
was like wait but it's becoming legal in
all these states like we had we had to
fight even your manager didn't even try
to pitch this get out the door to pitch
to it I was we've got the show than I
would have told you you never get [ __ ]
right but then also but pitching to
executives you get that you get that
thing where what are we gonna have you
do or what's your job gonna because you
know people don't really audiences don't
really like to watch shows about
comedians I'm like well [ __ ] Seinfeld
was super super successful crashing yes
a huge success what third season now on
HBO
Louie Louie there are plenty of shows
about comics that just well how come we
get them every movie I do has a comedian
all I do is write this [ __ ] I know we
pitch it gets shut down it's very
annoying
he's the real Mike Young on Instagram
atwitter yeah Twitter what the hell am I
own just real Mike yet I'm the real Mike
Young on Instagram Twitter I barely do
Facebook John because of all this I
never been good at social media bro I
got a higher social media program I'm
just not good at it
I don't do it I spend my time writing
not in the [ __ ] the social zone
outsource his services and just do some
social media for some of his comedian
friends I'm open to talking to anybody
than you know social media I'd rather
never go on
hell yeah hell yeah with the books we
give him 50 for Willie I'm come on
blondie got 20 50 - Brown Jug was Johnny
be sucking some conditioner tomorrow I'm
at the Lexington downtown LA and then
I'm with you this week Charlotte Sharla
just
[ __ ] my company I was you're wearing the
Rodrigo co-host of the year is wearing a
[ __ ] hair phone with [ __ ] duct
tape look at all thanks to you fresh mic
thank God for that
Shido [ __ ] headphones man no neither
of us have headphones don't we're gonna
have to donate some money to the whole
thing we're gonna start with air
conditioning [ __ ] hot in here